okay we're gonna pick up right where we
left off on Friday which was doing all
of the graphs okay now the point of the
graphs is not that you can just draw
pretty things the point of the grass is
so that you can use them to understand
what's going on and then have a look at
what we're doing today which is trig
functions of any magnitude okay so here
we've got our graph of y equals sine x
from naught to 360 and this is kind of
your standard graph and they asked you
to draw away a cosine X they should
provide you a domain noir 360 but if
they don't this is kind of like your
default all right so how did your graph
go one of the easiest ways to know
whether your graph is accurate or not
and I have even measured it for my own
one is again to use this same ratio that
we have learnt from the exact values
that we draw our triangle you know we
think okay this is the first thing we do
in any gym that requires cream it's a 30
60 90 triangle and the easiest ratio to
remember in a 30 60 90 triangle is sine
theta sine theta is 1/2 that's what I
always go back to you eat everything
else from that okay so sine 30 is
opposite one of my pot nice mess you use
that's 1 over 2 and it makes the last
side by Pythagoras the square root of 3
okay so now if I say well we're side fee
on here well it should be equal to 1/2
right
he's 1 so you can fairly precisely draw
in 1/2 because it'll be way ok then if
you've got another color there draw that
lightly across and see where it matches
up with the line see how accurate you
are so I've matched up mine to bear okay
so that's horizontally or vertically
rather what's happening so now if I met
that down to the angle that she
corresponds to Leicester you should
always mark it 90 180 270 360 they're
really critical angles okay it should
fall on 30 degrees which if you've got
90 degrees there should be about 1/3 the
way okay yep
okay so I'm going after this particular
example like 30 degrees because it gives
me a really easy measure of whether my
graph is accurate or not like if my
scales are no you don't need if anything
I'm doing it just for the sake
illustration okay however I am going to
use 30 degrees as my case study for this
particular question to illustrate what
I'm French shoot all right so I'm gonna
stay say that side equals equals 1/2 and
that's know okay fine I do don't be lazy
do right sine of 30 degrees okay because
we will progress away from using degrees
eventually and one of the ways that you
know what unit is gonna be on to you
is it with degrees it's written later on
when we learn radians
there's no unit provided and I'll let
you ever think about why that is when we
get there okay
all right now sight that is 100 is what
I keep saying if that is true that based
on the symmetry of my graph I can see
side of another angle that's also equal
to 1/2 right so if you were to visualize
I don't wanna put on there cuz my
diagram is gonna get pretty busy in a
second right if I were to put on there a
horizontal line through y equals 1/2 you
can see it's going to intersect once
they agrees and then again at it's gonna
be 150 isn't it right and you can see it
because of this shape being symmetrical
right so if I go 30 degrees this way and
I get a heart I should be able to go 30
degrees this way and also get a heart so
I'm even gonna draw that in that's 30
degrees plus from 0 and this is 30
degrees back from 180 which is what
gives me that 150 you just told me okay
so I'm gonna pop that in there
all right so now my second angle side
150 that's equal to 1/2 now there's a
couple other spots that are related to
this psalm thirty degree business right
because if I'm very good at 1/2 if I go
to - aha and do exactly the same thing -
aha okay remember how we were just
stating look if you're thirty degrees
this way don't get a half if you go 30
degrees that way you'll get a huh
I can do the same thing from these are
the two critical points okay for
instance for a hundred eighty degrees
instead of going back 30 degrees if I go
forward 30 degrees Sam that to 210
because of all the symmetry happening
here right instead of positive 1/2 I
should be expecting negative 1/2 so all
the way across and you can see that's
the point I'm getting okay so I've got
sine of 210 degrees that's okay and one
more for the sake of illustration what's
the last angle that's going to be
similar to this
let's go 330 it comes from he up and
back 30 degrees ego it's also equal to
negative
okay so I'm gonna rewrite these all of
these in terms of this little shift
business right so 30 degrees is kind of
like our basic angle in fact it's often
called the base angle in this situation
okay of all of these different angles so
this one here is sine of zero plus 30
degrees okay so from the origin I move
forward this one is from 180 and it goes
backwards 30 degrees right this one's
from 180 and it goes forward which gives
you two ten and this is from 360 and you
go backwards okay so this is what's
happening these are the angles on
comparing they all have this same value
right 1/2 if you want to go back to that
quadrants idea right which I'm not a
huge fan of but many people learn and
these kind of a good crutch to
understand what's going on okay if I
provided to you okay one of these angles
let's say 210 degrees I would look at
this and I would say 210 degrees in my
quadrants diagram which quadrant is 210
degrees it it's in the third one right
because this is 0 to 90 in other words
it's an acute angle okay this is 90 to
180 in other words it's obtuse and then
here we've got reflex angle right so 210
is gonna be here
180 to 75 I'll just complete this so
I've got 1 okay so these are both reflex
so I would say okay 210 degrees is down
here in this quadrant Oh then say okay
is sine positive or negative in that
quadrant and I've got my letters for you
telling me which functions are positive
which ones aren't right so 10 is
positive so is sine positive no it's not
for this it's not the letter there right
so it said okay sine of 210 degrees from
this quadrant down here is going to be
not positive it'll be negative
and the base angle inside they're highly
in there is 30 right so it's gonna be
minus side thing which is minus 1/2 as
we've already noticed okay so this is
the quadrants way of approaching it you
think every angle you work out which
angle which quadrant that angle is in
and then you think okay based on this
particular function am i positive prime
a negative and then you go from there
okay if I'll just I'll write that down
because I went through fairly quickly
right so number one identify the
quadrant okay so for instance if I said
all right it's like 330 you would
immediately say fourth quadrant yes you
got it quite good at working out which
angle is where number two excuse me you
identify the sign of which function
you're looking at right identify the
sign of the relevant function
so again if I said ok 330° you'd say
coin trick for this I'm positive or
negative in Quadrant 4 and it's a
negative right only cause is positive in
Quadrant 4 I've identified the site
right and then identify the face angle
that relates to that so for all of these
the base angle would be 30 ok let me
just quickly give you another one
suppose I said 250 degrees 250 degrees
what Quadro Mayan third quadrant okay so
what would be the base angle hiding
inside here if I'm in the third quadrant
right it's going to be 180 degrees plus
some angle right so this is actually
equal to 180 plus 70 you see that so 70
is the base anymore I've identified the
sign of that okay so side 250 would be
negative down there and then you'd find
out what minus sine 70 years okay so
that's that's the way that this
coordinates approach works I keep on
saying this right I'm not a huge fan I
think it's so much better to graph it
and you can just see it you don't have
to think positive maybe you just look at
where the graph is okay but that's fine
it's as it as it approached I think it's
alright okay on page 125 you have
exercise 4d there okay it says in
question 1
use the ASTC rule as they're afraid of
this used to determine the side plus or
minus of each of these trig ratios
that's all they're asking you to do they
just want you to work out this step here
identify the side of the relevant
function okay question 2 they did say
find the related angle for each of the
following so they're talking about this
related angle base angle two days to the
same thing in 3 right each trigger which
ratio is the ratio of an acute angle
with the correct science they say okay
bunches together with this making this
kind of statement right side 210 is
by this site 30 I prefer it if this but
if you like that that's fine